-We're back with
Jeffrey Wright.
This is a film that tackles
a lot of very serious issues,
and a lot of the film
is very serious,
but it's also a satire,
and it's really funny.
But playing satire is not the
way you would act in a comedy.
You have to be both aware of it,
but have to,
I would say, approach it
with a real sincerity.
-Well, I think that satire
in our film
is really tragedy in disguise.
-Yeah. [ Laughs ]
-Disguised as comedy, you know?
The film, you know,
we're a small film.
We shot in 26 days.
I think the budget of our film
was probably the catering budget
for the Batman movie.
-Yeah, yeah.
-But we're punching
above our weight,
and we really loved this script.
It's a small movie
with big ideas.
And these are conversations
that we're having in the film
that we're having across
our country right now,
conversations around race and
"ooh, scary."
-Yeah.
-Right?
And identity
and inclusion and history.
So it's really,
it's a story for the times.
I think that's
one of the reasons
that people
are responding to it.
But it's also a story
about a family
that's as insane
as anyone else's family.
So if you are born of a family,
you will find a place
in this film.
It's those elements
that kind of give it
this emotional depth,
while the satire and the social
commentary on on the other side,
you know, give it a buoyancy.
But you're able to take in these
otherwise difficult
conversations
and difficult issues,
because you're having a laugh
while you're doing it.
So it's kind of
a brilliant script
that Cord Jefferson,
our writer-director, wrote.
So it all begins with that.
And it's based on a novel
by Percival Everett
called Erasure,"
so check that out.
-It's really unique as well.
And it's funny because you say
it is about conversations,
and a lot of the film
are really funny,
wonderful conversation scenes.
And, you know,
Sterling K. Brown has been here.
Tracee Ellis Ross been here,
talking about how wonderful
it was to do such good writing.
It must, you know,
especially when you do
these big films like
the James Bond
franchise or Hunger Games,
to actually just be in a room
and acting with a scene partner,
where it is just about the words
and the emotion.
It just must feel so --
like theater, at some point.
-Well, you know, I mean,
I find enjoyment
and meaning in whatever I do.
I try to, if I choose well.
So the scale of the film
doesn't really mean
that it can't have real
emotional depth
and real meaning
to those of us who work on it.
In fact, we're as committed
as we are on any film.
This film, I guess, you know,
there was something about --
There were a couple of things.
One, that we had an opportunity
to talk about these issues
that, for example,
the first scene
takes place in a classroom
and there's a forbidden word
on the whiteboard behind me.
I'm a professor speaking to a
class about Southern literature,
and it's a discussion
that's happening in classrooms
all over the country.
It's a discussion
that's happening
in the political sphere
right now.
It's a conversation that
some people don't want to have.
They want to
pretend that the history
behind this stuff never existed.
There's another section
that may be traumatized by it,
you know, and so
it's a difficult conversation,
but we wanted to have these
conversations within this film.
We wanted to dive in that.
We thought it was important,
and timely, as I said.
But also it's a story of this
family, a family, you know,
that you haven't seen before
with folks like us,
but as I said, looks just
like your family.
-There you go.
I have a question.
[ Applause ]
You were doing some Zooms.
-Yeah.
-You know, back in the Zoom era,
when everybody was doing
press during Covid,
and you were often
in front of a turtle tank.
-Oh, yeah. Yeah.
-So you have two turtles?
-I have two turtles.
-Still with us?
-Yes, yeah.
-Okay.
-They're gonna probably outlive
all of us.
-Yeah.
-They're not a good pet to get
if you want to be in it
for the short run.
-Yeah.
If you're doing it on a whim,
no, they're probably about...
-Did you get them
at the same time?
-Both at the same time.
Actually, my daughter came home
with her mom from Canal Street
with a little brown paper bag,
and there were two half dollar
sized turtles in there.
They're now,
like, dinner plate size.
One is named Nancy Nippleton.
-Sure.
Classic turtle name.
-He's the male.
-He? Okay.
-You know.
And Mouse is the female.
They were named. We had no idea.
But when Mouse laid eggs,
it was clear
that Nancy Nippleton
had fertilized them.
So hey, you know, we're fluid.
We're fluid, baby.
-These are modern turtles.
We're living in the new era.
-Yeah, don't be so uptight, bro.
Yeah.
-Congrats on the film.
-Thank you.
-Congrats on the nomination.
Thanks for being back.
-Thank you, sir.
Jeffrey Wright.
"American Fiction"
in theaters now.
We'll be right back
with Jon Cryer, everybody.